plus redoutable que l'héroïne plus
dévastatrice que le krach plus discrète
aussi que l’extasie les drogues de
synthèse débarquent en France
c'est vraiment une drogue hautement
toxique qui rend vraiment à fond
on est dedans puisqu'on a déjà eu des
cas et que je crois qu'on a intérêt à
prévenir les jeunes filles notamment
je ne me souviens pas comment je me suis
retrouvée dans la rue
[Musique]
les praticiens sont très préoccupés par
l'augmentation des drogues de synthèse
autrefois on avait un comprimé par mois
à analyser maintenant c'est 10 par jour
[Musique]
c'est une tragédie pour la jeunesse à
bien des égards
[Musique]
c'est au cours d'une bonne à l'enquête
sur la mort d'un jeune de 25 ans que cet
homme le commandant Archambault et son
équipe réalise une des plus inquiétantes
saisies de drogue jamais effectuées en
France
l'été dernier la brigade des stupes
découvraient au bord d'une rivière près
d'Arpajon dans un ancien lavoir un
laboratoire clandestin on y fabriquait
de la drogue de synthèse du GHB
oyer il s'agit du de la cabane que l'on
a découvert au mois d'août qui servait
de laboratoire à l'individu qui avait
fabriqué ce fameux GHB
on a affaire
à un individu qui est absolument aucune
connaissance en chimie qui s'est procuré
facilement la documentation et nous
a-t-il dit par l'intermédiaire des
PagesJaunes du téléphone à contacter des
laboratoires qui ont accepté de lui
fournir des produits de base dans ce
cabanon les policiers découvrent des
produits chimiques et 4 kilos d'une
poudre blanche il pense aussitôt à de la
cocaïne mais ça n'en est pas il s'agit
d'un produit alors totalement inconnu en
France le chimiste a donc été présenté
au juge d'instruction après quatre jours
de garde à vue et puis il a été écroué
pendant trois jours je crois et ensuite
il est obligé de le remettre en liberté
puisque ce produit n'était pas classé
stupéfiant à l'office central des
stupéfiants ne cache pas son embarras
lorsqu’on découvre que des drogues
synthétiques sont en train de détrôner
chez les jeunes les drogues classiques
comme la cocaïne ou l'héroïne dans la
catégorie 18-25
c'est un peu la drogue de papa c'est les
drogues c'est un petit peu aussi les
modes vous savez donc
les drogues synthétiques sont arrivées
sur le marché grâce à cette mode grâce
au concept je dirais musique techno une
certaine un certain mode de consommation
et puis on a vu arriver aussi donc des
produits qui
sont arrivés parfois de la consommation
légale c'est à dire le Rohypnol on a la
kétamine qui était anesthésie qui était
qui est utilisée maintenant en
association on a le GHB ce qui fait que
on a le dôme maintenant le Nexus bon il
y a toute la palette et on saisit tout
ça les douanes sont mises en alerte mais
elles avouent leurs quasi impuissant
fistiquer le Cisco scan un scanner qui
permet de passer en revue tout ce que
transporte un 38 tonnes inefficace quand
il s'agit de trouver une molécule
chimique c'est
difficile à déceler dans le chargement
d'un camion parce que comme ça n'a pas
vraiment de de forme
nous n'avons pas vraiment de repères et
puis les la densité est beaucoup moins
grande aussi et nous jouons beaucoup
avec la densité la couleur et ce qui
fait que c'est plus difficile
reste pour les douaniers le flair ou la
chance en témoigne cette saisie record
réalisée le 28 octobre dernier à
Dunkerque 400 000 pilules compensées
être de l'extasie mais ce n'était pas de
l'ecstasie c'était du DOB une molécule
de synthèse dont la puissance est de 100
fois supérieure à l'ecstasie à la
direction régionale de l'île force et de
constater que c'est à une véritable
invasion qu'on assiste aujourd'hui en
France
les résultats de la France entière en
matière d’extasie en 1997 c'était
environ 170 000 doses dans la direction
régionale de Dunkerque cette année à
l'heure où je vous parle nous sommes à
843 villes je pense que les chiffres
parlent de même vous rendez compte
qu'une dans une direction régionale nous
avons à peu près 6 fois plus que les
résultats de la France entière l'an
dernier en fait on assiste une course de
vitesse le tout c'est de ne pas se
laisser dépasser et en fait il faut
qu'on adapte absolument notre réaction
pour qu'on ait une capacité de réaction
qui soit identique à l'imagination des
des producteurs de ces produits ici
perplexe les chimistes du laboratoire
des douanes découvrent chaque jour de
nouveaux produits qu'il ne connaissaient
pas il aura fallu par exemple 24 heures
pour identifier la présence de DOB dans
ces cachets
est une nouvelle forme d'extasie
qui est 100 fois plus puissante environ
que le MDMA qu'on reçoit le plus
couramment c'est à dire que on a le même
effet sur
système nerveux central avec 2 mg de
qu'avec 200 mg d'un extasie courant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ici aux États-Unis que la plupart
des drogues de synthèse ont été
inventées ou recyclées avant de
traverser l'Atlantique en Californie ou
ces nouvelles drogues font déjà des
ravages la police est totalement
dépassée le fléau a pris une ampleur à
la taille du continent américain avec
pour conséquence l'émergence d'une
nouvelle criminalité
[Musique]
il y a eu soit disant des cas de viol
après ingestion sans le savoir de cette
drogue du viol comme on l'appelle ici
95% des personnes ici le son pour des
crimes qui ont un rapport avec les
stupéfiants soit parce qu'ils en vend
soit parce qu'ils en achètent ou encore
parce qu'ils veulent pour s'acheter de
la drogue ils vont même jusqu'à faire
des kidnapping pour se procurer de la
drogue ici il est dans un état second et
il est armé
de la drogue plus une arme un cocktail
qui demande des précautions extrêmes les
policiers sont sur armés ils ne savent
pas comment le toxicomane peut réagir
la tension monte mais finalement le
jeune homme est après
c'est dans le monde de la nuit que les
dégâts sont les plus visibles mais les
statistiques sont difficiles à établir
on parle de 200 des 16 officielles
depuis 5 ans mais les cas seraient
beaucoup plus nombreux le GHP ne laisse
aucune trace dans l'organisme il est
pourtant le principal coupable le GHB a
été surnommé la drogue du voile parfait
incolore sans saveur il est aisément
versé dans les verres des victimes alors
insoupes les viols sont GHB ont ne les
compte plus au point que le GHB est
devenu la hantise des établissements de
nuit seule prévention des pancartes dans
les toilettes pour mettre en garde les
clients surveiller votre verre
[Musique]
ancien propriétaire du légendaire Studio
54 à New York Mark flunchman Rennes
aujourd'hui ici à Los Angeles sur cette
boîte haut de gamme état des lieux avec
un roi de la nuit qui pensait avoir tout
vu tout entendu
synthèse j'en avais jamais entendu
parler avant et non pas vraiment non
elle porte le désinitiales comme LBA ou
GHP
c'est ce qui identifie le procédé
chimique ou les composantes
de ce qui prenait le pire de tout c'est
quand on s'est rendu compte que des
hommes ont donné aux femmes pour faire
d'elle ensuite ce qu'ils voulaient
cette nouvelle drogue le GHP c'est
vraiment la drogue
[Musique]
dans certains quartiers le SAMU commence
seulement à reconnaître les victimes de
ces drogues nouvelles qui souvent n'ont
pas d'Antibes il ne se passe pas une
semaine sans qu'une de ces nouvelles
molécules ne fasse des victimes
nous avons retrouvé l'une d'entre elles
Adriana
il y a deux ans après avoir sans doute
absorbé du GHB son témoignage a conduit
à la condamnation de deux hommes à 97
ans de prison ils ont été reconnus
coupables d'avoir violé 18 femmes à ce
jour en utilisant du
ghback
était dans un chocolat ou quelque chose
comme ça c'est possible
j'avais beaucoup de mal à effectuer le
moindre mouvement on m'a donné des
ordres de coucher comme si ou comme ça
à l'appartement je me souviens pas
comment je me suis retrouvée dans la
chambre des trucs de ce genre
j'avais l'impression d'être dans le
brouillon ma mémoire était très floue
j'ai commencé à me souvenir
notre expérience auprès des victimes que
nous recevons nous montrent que c'est
drogues sont une arme fatale elles sont
aussi dangereuses qu'un pistolet ou un
couteau parce que non seulement vous
pouvez rendre quelqu'un inconscient dans
le but de le violer mais vous pouvez
aussi le tuer c'est possible avec ce
type de drogue la plupart des victimes
sont des adolescents
c'était une véritable tragédie pour la
jeunesse
nous devons changer nos méthodes
on doit également éduquer les policiers
pour leur apprendre comment réagir face
à ces viols
comment trouver des preuves
quel test ou quels examens pratiqués
auparavant
éduquer la police c'est aujourd'hui une
des priorités des autorités à Hollywood
dans l'un des commissariats les plus
chauds de la ville la patrouille est
conviée à suivre un cours sur ces
nouvelles drogues
une détective de la brigade des stupes
le lieutenant Portal et la cour rouvrir
les yeux à des policiers qui ne savent
ni commencer prendre ni reconnaître tous
ces nouveaux produits sur le marché
une carburateur
combien d'entre vous ont déjà entendu
mes discours sur les nouvelles drogues
aucun bien
pour commencer si je vous offre une
gorgée de ça vous vous semblez faire un
peu de muscu
si ça vous aidait dans la gonflette vous
en parliez certainement pas
un des problèmes de nos rencontres en ce
moment et qui est un véritable cauchemar
pour nous histoire de l'ordre c'est ça
la drogue la plus facile à fabriquer et
la plus difficile pour une identifier il
n'y a rien de plus dur à identifier que
le Gama hydroxique JHB l'ecstasyllique
combien d'entre vous ont déjà vu du GHB
dans des boîtes de nuit quelqu'un
d'entre vous peut-être c'est pareil que
tout le monde dans cette salle en a vu
mais vous ne savez pas le reconnaître ça
c'est un spread pour cheveux à trouver
dans le sac d'une femme
je n'aurais jamais pensé à 5000
très avancé d'intoxication en général
accompagnée de vomissements presque tout
le monde vomit avec ce truc là la
respiration s'arrête quasiment en
général si respiration par minute ce qui
est très près de la mort il ne
réagissent pas quand il est touchés
la victime est toujours sous une emprise
très puissante qui la rend sexuellement
si vous voulez en donner à une femme et
que vous aimez le sexe et le vomi réunis
et bien les gars cette robe c'est pour
vous deux choses que nous sommes sur ce
que stimule la sexualité et provoque un
comportement agressif
la police n'a pas fini d'être déroutée
par l'explosion du marché de ces drogues
de synthèse ce type de drogue ne circule
plus par les réseaux traditionnels de
trafiquants les consommateurs les
usagers sont difficiles à identifier
contrairement au petit milieu détoxin
venait du milieu des cultures ce sont
eux qui ont démarré tout ça dans les
années 80 alors qu'il cherchait une
alternative au stéroïde qui n’était plus
invente libre
ils ont commencé à en abuser c'est là
que ça a été interdit mais personne ne
s'en est réellement préoccupé personne
n'avait imaginé que ça prendrait une
telle ampleur
le lieutenant for alta en est conscient
tellement n'est qu'au début d'une longue
traque pour en apprendre toujours plus
elle n'hésite pas à descendre dans la
rue ce soir-là elle a rendez-vous sur un
parking avec un consommateur de GHB il
est culturiste il fabrique lui-même son
GHB depuis 6 ans quelques-uns de ses
amis en sont morts il veut tout arrêter
je voulais vous montrer à quoi ça
ressemble en général
soyez la trace blanche
c'est aussi rapide que ça
les orgasmes sont invraisemblables aussi
bien pour les hommes que pour les femmes
c'est incroyable vraiment
évidemment je pourrais l'arrêter mais je
suis ici pour m'informer c'est une
nouvelle drogue et nous essayons tous
d'en apprendre davantage il y a beaucoup
de questions en jeu et c'est une chance
pour moi pour les voir de l'ordre dans
leur ensemble de bénéficier tout
simplement
moi je ne suis pas passé par là par où
vous êtes passés je n'en ai jamais pris
je n'ai donc aucun intérêt à vous
arrêter
j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui sont à ce truc
là
mort de quelqu'un même si je ne le
connais pas même si la chatte ailleurs
je ne veux plus être mêlé à ça
c'est en France dans les années 75
chercheurs le professeur Labory avait
mis au point le GHB utilisez un certain
temps par le SAMU comme anesthésiant il
avait été très vite délaissé au profit
d'un autre produit moine nocif moins
dangereux aujourd'hui même si nous
sommes encore
américaine le GHB nous revient comme un
boomerang et brouille les cartes de la
lutte antidrogue
pour le chef des stups Gilles Leclerc la
police n'est pas préparée à faire face à
cette invasion
[Musique]
notamment la dernière
dont on parle qui est GHB nous on est
encore la chance pour l'instant on peut
être touché trop par le phénomène de
décès lié à ces produits on va on y va
tout droit si les gens continuent ça
c'est clair
tout phénomène nouveau bien sûr
c'est vrai que c'est difficile de les
anticiper notamment en matière de drogue
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
d'anticiper et c'est pour ça qu'on est
parfois un peu désarmé dans l'action
c'est une autre approche c'est
d'approche plus de terrain régional et
local c'est c'est un petit peu du
maillage de territoire peut-être à
développer mieux pour nous parce que les
services départementaux ou les services
locaux soient beaucoup plus à l'écoute
essaye de d'exploiter les choses la
découverte de ces nouvelles drogues est
un véritable casse-tête pour les stups
c'est psychotropes très puissant bien
souvent sont des variantes de produits
déjà interdits mais des variantes du
coup ils ne sont pas classés dans le
tableau des stupéfiants pour le docteur
Hautefeuille expert en toxicologie ces
nouvelles manipulations moléculaires
peuvent échapper à la loi pendant
plusieurs années donc ça c'est un
exemple pour montrer l'évolution qu'il y
a à l'intérieur des drogues de synthèse
là on part du radical amphétamine donc
quelque chose de très classique à partir
de ça on va rajouter d'autres radicaux
qui donnent un nouveau produit qui est
connu sous le nom d'ecasie
l'ecstasy va faire partie de la liste
des produits stupéfiants donc interdit
en 90 à partir de 90 il y a des
chimistes qui vont prendre ce cette
formule de l'ecstasie qui vont par un
tour de passe-passe faire sortir ce
radical là pour le on en rajouter un
autre ce qui est une manœuvre chimique
assez simple on a un nouveau produit qui
est le MBDB qui est un produit avec des
effets différents mais de même type que
l'electasie et ce produit ne sera rendu
illégal qu'à partir de 1996 c'est à dire
que là on a l'exemple de deux molécules
tout à fait voisines avec un flux
juridique pendant 5-6 ans c'est à dire
le temps que ce produit soit classé
stupéfiant et ça c'est intéressant parce
que c'est tout le problème que pose les
drogues chimiques c'est-à-dire qu'il y
aura toujours une différence et un
retard entre l'imagination des chimistes
et les possibilités légales d'interdire
telle ou tel type de produit que c'est
effectivement l'image du toxicoman qui
va changer là on va vers une espèce de
banalisation de la prise de produit
chimiques
qui fait que une un pourcentage
important de la population est
probablement de plus en plus importante
de la population va se mettre à prendre
des produits chimiques pour pouvoir
faire face au quotidien
les juristes nagent dans le brouillard
dans cet univers des drogues de synthèse
tout va trop vite et l'on doit jouer aux
petits chimistes pour déterminer au
milieu de tous ces produits ce qui est
vraiment de la drogue à l'hôpital Henri
Vidal on s'aperçoit qu'il est de plus en
plus compliqué de placer une molécule
qui a potentiellement des dizaines de
dérivés aux effets identiques au point
qu'on parle aujourd'hui de famille de
drogue tous ces produits sont fabriqués
à partir de produits de base qu'on
appelle le précurseur
le précurseur des amphétamines un
produit en tant que tel qui n'est pas
illégal mais qui transformait peut
devenir une drogue redoutable
le professeur Lagier président de la
commission des stupéfiants n'est
parfaitement conscient mais il est
impuissant
pour GHB c'est le précurseur qui voyage
en les valises c'est de Fricker
extrêmement simple qui voyagent dans des
valises et puis au moment où on fait la
synthèse et puis juste avant la synthèse
et des produits complètement anodins et
après la synthèse d'un produit
redoutable donc on est incapable de
casser comme stupéfiant des précurseurs
l'Europe est très inquiète elle a
demandé une procédure rapide de
sensibilisation sinon de classement il
faut des rapidités de réaction tout à
fait augmenter puisque le problème
s'accélère de manière singulière et puis
à partir de là c'est c'est ça qui compte
c'est pas c'est pas d'avoir la
performance de classer un produit de
produits de plus et d'avoir des
principes bien clairs aux yeux tout le
monde via du trafiquants vis-à-vis de
tout le monde et que les gens sachent ce
qui risque et aussi que le consommateur
soit averti parce que il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ne sont pas du tout avertis
retour à Los Angeles ou pour les dealers
les drogues dures comme l'héroïne sont
bien moins rentables aujourd'hui les
drogues de synthèse en revanche sont un
malheur elles sont censées stimuler les
sens moduler l'humeur affronter la
réalité sans phobie le dealer apprend à
jouer un rôle nouveau celui de formation
Underworld Franky et dealer de GHB et
autres cachets du bonheur comme on les
surnomme lui-même a de plus en plus de
mal à faire la distinction entre
stupéfiants et simple molécules de
Nirvana
[Musique]
déjà synthétisée
à l'entrée ou à la sortie des boîtes
s'il trouve quelque chose vous pourrez
éventuellement vous en sortir en disant
par exemple que c'est une solution pour
volontiers de contact mais vous pourrez
toujours courir le risque de vous faire
arrêter
mais il y aura toujours quelqu'un pour
vouloir les interdire pour soi-disant
des raisons de sécurité ou autre et
c'est pour ça que ça donne une course
pour être toujours en avance sur la loi
on doit toujours fabriquer de nouveaux
produits
identiques mais légèrement différent
en tout cas ça provoque toujours avec
ces deux effets
et pour ceux qui ne veulent pas passer
par les dealers rien de plus facile ou
presque d'acheter les produits de base
pour fabriquer soi-même sa drogue à
partir d'un produit comme le GBL par
exemple mélangez à de l'eau ou avalée
pur il se transforme en GHB par
oxygénation nous sommes à Passadena une
banlieue proche de Los Angeles avec une
caméra cachée nous essayons de nous
procurer du GHB dans un magasin pour
culturiste on trouve ici toutes sortes
de produits pour améliorer les
performances
réticence de la vendeuse mais réticence
de courte durée le produit est interdit
mais disponible elle nous donne
finalement un flacon
[Musique]
le docteur vléa est toxicologue sur
l'Internet il a déjà repéré des
centaines de dropshimiques et leur mode
d'emploi pour les fabriquer chez soi
véritable encyclopédie l'Internet lui
permet de suivre l'évolution des drogues
dites de design à l'échelle mondiale en
particulier celle du GHB et de ses
dérives
on peut penser que le GHB il a utilisé
en France ou dans tout le reste de
l'Europe dont nous en pourcentage
beaucoup plus fort qu'on imagine nous ce
qui concerne la toxicité du produit donc
les données sont assez difficiles à
saisir parce que c'est un produit qui se
volatilise presque au bout d'une heure
devant l'organisme donc on trouve plus
de trace et c'est assez difficile de de
faire le lien entre des dégâts de
toxiques qu'on trouve dans Urgences et
une prise de GHB c'est un produit qui
aura beaucoup d'avenir en France du fait
de son moindre coût de fabrication de la
facilité de trouver sur internet qu'on
procédure de fabrication ingrédients et
c'est un drogue futuriste à la drogue du
21e siècle
et pour s'en convaincre il suffit de se
connecter en effet sur les sites
américains de l'Internet on y trouve pas
moins de 179 formules dérivées du MDMA
l'ecstasy
[Musique]
San Francisco le berceau du
psychédélisme du LSD de l'expérimental
pas très loin de là dans la petite ville
de Lafayette le parrain de l'ecstasy de
la plupart de ces molécules travaillent
toujours à mettre au point de nouvelles
drogues
Alexandre schulgain et biochimiste la
publication de Pical et Tikal ces deux
livres références ont suscité au sein du
monde scientifique à la fois de
l'admiration et de les mois à 72 ans cet
ancien professeur de l'université de
beurkley est un pionnier de
l'exploration de la conscience pour lui
la chimie nous offre les moyens
d'évoluer vers un monde meilleur où l'on
pourra choisir ses états d'âme en
fonction de ses besoins Alexandre
schulgin a accepté de nous recevoir dans
son laboratoire
je suis mon propre cobaye je fais tous
les tests préliminaires sur moi je n'ai
jamais publié de résultats à moins que
moi ou mes associés n'étaient le produit
pour savoir si en effet c'était sans
aucun risque et si ça servait à quelque
chose
là mon intérêt n'est pas d'inventé des
drogues mon intérêt c'est de créer des
outils de recherche et s'il y a des
applications médicales tant mieux
mais je ne suis pas dans le business de
la drogue je fabrique des outils je suis
un fabricant d'outils et je crois que
c'est ça en art les gens disent que vous
créez des drogues pour que les autres
tombent dedans non moi je crée des drops
pour explorer ceux qui se passe quand
les gens sont intoxiqués quand ils ont
des retours de mémoire on se souviennent
de leurs rêves bien encore quand il
change de dimension
et ça ça a toujours été une véritable
motivation chez l'animal qui est l'homme
les gens pensent ceci cela toujours pour
changer leur état de conscience tu vois
qu'il leur est inconscience ils vont à
l'église pour changer leur état de
conscience ils dorment
dans chaque société les gouvernements
veulent obtenir des comportements
conventionnels sans écart des
comportements prévisibles c'est vrai
qu'il y a toujours des gens qui essayent
de ne pas rentrer dans ce moule
le système dans lequel nous vivons dans
la plupart des pays du monde et basé sur
l'élimination de l'individualité car
avec elle les gens deviennent
imprévisibles
les idées très personnelles et les
expériences du professeur schulgin ne
sont pas interdites mais sous haute
surveillance pendant notre visite la
police débarque à l'improviste le
professeur choubi est arrêté plus
séquestré chez lui
s'il vous plaît
quelques heures plus tard une armée
d'agents de DEA accompagnée de camions
d'analyses chimiques et d'un mandat de
perquisition passons laboratoire au
penfar mais il ne pouvons rien
le discours est sur un timbre poste on
peut déposer en microgramme des
centaines de doses de principes actifs
de n'importe quel drogue et puis on peut
aussi et puisque c'est ça la notion même
du design rock mais proposé au marché
des produits qui
multiplient et accumulent les effets
c'est à dire qu'au début vous êtes comme
si après vous êtes comme ça et à la fin
vous serez autrement
et donc la dernière barrière qui est le
rituel d'un produit c'est à dire diluer
par exemple l'héroïne
l'arrêterait se piquer avec ses règles à
l'intérieur de dans son isolement ou à
l'intérieur d'un groupe et bien ça c'est
encore
l'obstacle qui faisait que
très peu de gens consommaient parce que
ceux qui consommaient étaient des gens
qui étaient déjà en rupture avec la
société le jour où consommer des drogues
notamment pas dans une rupture parce
qu'il suffit d'un valet une pilule et
bien dans ce cas-là il y aura plus de
rituels qui va nous protéger et donc
tout le monde pourra devenir
consommateur de synthèse
[Applaudissements]
un monde sans drogue paraît aujourd'hui
pour beaucoup totalement
utopique et sans doute faudra-t-il
apprendre à vivre avec la réponse au
raz-de-marée des molécules de synthèse
n'est sans doute pas pour demain et
pourtant il y a urgence